hoy les voy a compartir una historia que
es la historia de una reflexión
una reflexión que surgió curiosamente
durante un desayuno
uno de esos desayunos de sábado cuando
hay un poquito más de tiempo y no hay
que correr
estaba con mi hijo antonio de 19 años
que debe andar por ahí y para ponerle
tema al desayuno le dije
antonio qué es lo que más te llama la
atención de mi profesión como periodista
y claro yo me esperaba una de esas
respuestas de cajón que diga no se
conoce es mucha gente has viajado
pero no la respuesta que me dio mi hijo
me dejó sorprendido y me dejó un poco
shockeado
me dijo lo que más me impresiona es como
cómo pierdes amigos
y le digo es lo que más impresiona
sí bueno no sólo eso me impresiona cómo
te ganas de insultos cómo te peleas con
los papás de mis compañeros como como te
dicen horrores de las redes sociales
como cómo nos han llegado amenazas
etcétera la verdad de esa respuesta me
dejó me dejó preocupado me dejó
decepcionado
mi hijo tenía una idea muy poco
romántica sobre mi oficio pero pero me
planteo una pregunta que creo que ha
sido clave en esta en este tránsito vale
la pena
vale la pena
vale la pena haber perdido por ejemplo
la amistad de una colega hace poco
porque escribía algo duro sobre su
trabajo
ha valido la pena distanciarme de mis
amigos
por las cosas que he dicho
ha valido la pena qué sé yo
que me han sacado de un chat de whatsapp
porque esa que algo publique algo que
afectaba a la esposa de alguien que
estaba en ese chat
han valido la pena estos insultos
han valido la pena las amenazas
que han sufrido mis hijos
ha valido todo eso la pena
ha valido la pena me pregunto a raíz de
estas de esta conversación con mi hijo
ha valido la pena
que haya sacrificado incluso mi salud
será que todas estas angustias todos
estos pesares
han causado que yo tenga una enfermedad
incurable
todas estas preguntas me llevaron a un
episodio un episodio que yo creo que es
de los más más no sé si la palabra sea
traumáticos más intensos de mi vida que
fue mi descuido el día que me quedé sin
trabajo y todo por no haber sido capaz
de cumplir una promesa
una promesa que suena muy fácil de
cumplir que le hice a mis jefes pero que
no fui capaz de honrar porque porque iba
en contra de algo que es fundamental que
es la libertad
la promesa había sido quedarme callado
ocurrió en agosto del 2015
mi jefes
del medio donde trabajaba me habían
llamado y de una forma muy cordial y muy
incluso cariñosa me dijeron que yo era
un problemita
que por las cosas que escribían
y sobre todo por las cosas que decían
redes sociales
que les traía muchos problemas con el
gobierno y que la situación no era fácil
y que había posibilidad de demandas
y amenazas
y que la empresa no estaba en una
situación como para soportar esas
amenazas de esos problemas entonces me
hablaron de la prudencia me hablaron de
que sí de que un exabrupto mío podría
costarles mucho a una empresa que ya
empleaba a 600 o 800 familias ya no me
acuerdo bien
entonces yo escuché todo esto y
comprendí
y tal vez
servir de esa reunión
debo confesar triste muy triste
de alguna forma decepcionado
pero también comprendía comprendía y me
parecía que la prudencia de la que me
hablaba no era ninguna locura
incluso salir pensando que sí que quizás
era una buena idea quedarme callado
qué es lo que yo digo tampoco es que
valga tanto la pena como para poner en
riesgo tantas cosas
y eso fue un jueves
y la promesa de que les cuento que hice
ese día la verdad no duró mucho
duro hasta el sábado
ese sábado yo llegué tenía trabajo turno
los periodistas tenemos muchas veces
turnos los fines de semana
llegué a trabajar y empezaron a pasar
cosas muy graves en este país
una cosa decían los voceros del gobierno
y otras cosas decía la gente yo recibía
muchas llamadas y me di cuenta que
estaban pasando cosas muy graves que de
alguna forma había que contarlas
que no me podía quedar callado
colegas que venían venían y me decían
martín qué hacemos cómo contamos esto
aquí no nos van a dejar
la prudencia la prudencia y aguantaba la
prudencia la prudencia
hasta que un momento no pude
no pude y fui
abrir mi cuenta de twitter que había
prometido no abrir
y bloom
conte
dije
lo que pensaba y lo que yo sabía que
estaba pasando
el lunes
y va hacia mi trabajo
temprano no había ni siquiera llegado y
recibí la llamada de mi jefe
de la forma más cariñosa y respetuosa me
dijo que no suba oficina sino que vaya
por el departamento de recursos humanos
era lógico había roto la promesa tenía
que salir de ese trabajo estaba
despedido
y claro como
no tenía otra cosa que hacer que irme a
la casa y ahí me senté en el sofá como
buen desempleado
hasta que tipo 2 de la tarde dos y
cuarto llegaron mis hijos
recuerdo clarísimo
mi hijo antonio primero llegó me vio y
me dijo
te despidieron él es más nada
atrás de mi amiga rosario
y yo vi que los ojos se les llenaron de
lágrimas y se fue a su cuarto y dijo
no vamos a tener con qué pagar el
colegio para y se fue a llorar
debo confesar que esta reacción
de alguna forma me decepcionó salió
esperaba más solidaridad más cariño
pero luego entendí que a esa edad estos
tendrían 14 15 años estos temas son
difíciles de entender
ese día fue el día en que por primera
vez me surgió la pregunta de si valió la
pena
una pregunta que la fui contestando muy
poco muy muy rápido y que fue una
contestación que vino de la gente de la
calle de una señora que paró el carro en
las 6 de diciembre y yo iba a la
ecovía y se baja del carro y me felicitó
y me agradeció
me agradeció dijo por todas las cosas
que había dicho en su nombre que ella no
había podido decir
la respuesta vino de un cajero del
supermercado que me pidió que me tomaron
a self y con él
de un conductor de uve
que mi hijo llegaba en la noche y me
dijo papá el señor del über quiere
conocerte ya sabe quién eres
y el señor me dijo gracias gracias
porque usted ha dicho muchas cosas que
nosotros no hemos podido decir
fue el agradecimiento de la gente lo que
me fue dando la respuesta
una respuesta que poco a poco fue
calmando miami y que fue calmando y
respondiendo a mis hijos a mis hijos que
no solamente eran las problemas de estos
del colegio y de que nos íbamos a quedar
sin plata dice que que les afectaba sino
también las amenazas los insultos y
todas esas cosas que habían pasado
poco a poco
fueron comprendiendo que todo eso que
habíamos pasado esos momentos
complicados
habían valido la pena y que a pesar de
todas las obras ellos veían que había
gente
que sentía agradecimiento por lo que yo
había hecho
fue así como en esa paz que fui
sintiendo en mis hijos y en el apoyo de
mi esposa manuela que también debe estar
por aquí que fui entendiendo que todo
aquello había valido la pena si valió la
pena y sobre todo porque mis hijos y
esto es algo que para mí es muy
importante sobre todo porque mis hijos
no tendrían nunca de que avergonzarse de
su papá
había sido fiel a sus principios y a sus
valores
creo que también valió la pena
porque siento que los principios y
valores
es algo que no tiene precio
ese día es este sábado traicioné una
promesa pero fui fiel a lo más
importante que puede tener una persona
su propia condición humana de ser humano
callar es una traición a esa condición
porque como decía el gran escritor
salman rushdie
nosotros nos convertimos en seres
humanos el momento en que nos sentamos
en una caverna frente al fuego a
contarnos las historias de de ese día de
las cacerías de lo que nos había pasado
esta necesidad de contarnos de estas
historias
la libertad de expresión
señores
la libertad de expresión no sólo es del
fundamento de una sociedad abierta y
democrática que es la única que abre
paso al progreso y al bienestar
la libertad de expresión también es el
cimiento más profundo de la condición
humana
hablar con libertad sin que nos lo
impidan es lo que nos hace personas
pero para qué sirve la libertad de
expresión quizás muchos de ustedes se
pregunten
y yo les entiendo eso entiendo que
muchos digan es mejor quedarse
calladitos
y tener seguridades
pero no
no es así
la libertad de expresión permite que
todas las otras libertades y derechos
existan es la madre de todas las
libertades como va a exigir que se
respete la vida si no es hablando
como van a pedir a los gobiernos que no
despilfarre el dinero
o que no se lo roben si no es hablando
diciéndolo
como no pedir compasión
como no declarar amor si no es hablar
la libertad de expresión es
importantísima señores
es la única posibilidad para que el
mundo en que vivimos existan diversidad
de ideas y de opiniones
sin debate la sociedad no crece está
muerta por eso
el desarrollo no es posible sin esa
libertad de expresión
muchos me han felicitado
y me han dicho que he sido muy valiente
por decir las cosas que he dicho y otros
no han podido decir
yo debo confesarles que eso no es
valentía
eso es miedo
es el miedo el horripilante miedo a
callarse
a callarse cuando alguien
te lo obliga
porque casarse en esas condiciones es la
peor de las traiciones que uno puede
hacerse a sí mismo
es tóxico
bueno entonces después del despido
en el desempleo decidí que tenía que
seguir hablando y diciendo las cosas que
pensaba y que veía
entonces con otros colegas con otros
colegas periodistas que pasaban una
situación parecida a la mía decidí
fundar un medio que se llama cuatro
pelagatos
y seguía hablando desde allí
y los problemas otra vez
por hablador
como un juicio que me puso un ex
presidente que me quería a verme en la
cárcel por haber afectado según el decía
su buena honra su buen nombre etcétera
y saben que gane el juicio
y lo gane porque
el país había descubierto y se había
dado cuenta
que lo peor que le puede pasar a una
sociedad es aceptar el silencio obligado
eso
me hizo pensar que todo había valido la
pena
ahora tengo cientos miles de
incertidumbres de angustias miedos
incertidumbre sobre la estabilidad
laboral sobre tu chicas será que voy a
poder seguir pagando la educación de mis
hijos
incertidumbre miedo sobre sobre el
futuro de mi familia el futuro de mi
país
pero por favor créanme que tengo una
gran certidumbre que le gana a todas las
dudas ya todas las incertidumbres
esa es la inmensa tranquilidad de poder
decirles a mis hijos quién es
la mejor herencia que podía haber estado
yo estoy convencido de que ellos podrán
hablar de su paz así me dicen paz
sin que se avergüencen de él
porque su paz fue fiel a sí mismo
y jamás
se traiciona
está esta historia es una historia
es una historia triste
es una historia que hubiera preferido no
tener que vivir ni compartirla acá
sin duda hubiera preferido tener una
vida en la que nadie me hubiera obligado
a callar
una historia
en la que nadie hubiera obligado a
callar a nadie
hubiera preferido no tener que contarles
de historia
pero no tenía otra
y no tenía otra por qué
porque todo se trata de la libertad
[Aplausos]